>> Joel: YOU GOT IT.
FOUL.
HE SAID YOU ARE   PICKS HIS POC.
BREAK OPPORTUNITY.
A.D. IS RUNNING.
BRADLEY LOBSUP,
THAT'S THE YOUNG
>> Matt:JULIUS.
MAKE SURE YOU'RE WORKING , I NE
TO GET BACK INTO LEADING THE NB
IS WESTBR HENINE
POINTS. AND LOOKED VERY
CONFIDENT.
>>>>Stacey: I WANT TO GO HIGHER
OH, DAVIS!
MVP CONVERSATION. KNICKS.
ENDED LAST SEASON AS A MEMBER IN
OF THE KINGS AND LOOK AT THAT
HUSTLE TO COME UP WITH THAT  TH
OPPOSITE TEAM. THE DRIBBLE
HESITATION.
CAM, RISING BASKET AND
HE PUTS I ID WORKS ON HOLIDAY.
SHOVELS TO MOBLEY -- OH, BIG FEE
OVER STEWART.OFF TWO
FEET.
WATCH THIS.
JUST NOT HIGH
STANLEY JOHNSON.
>> Vince: THE HAWKS AHEAD,
COCK IT BACK AND THROWBANE